weaknesses that can't be covered so now
artemis he's brought his king across and
we will see the players repeat the
position there's just no way forward no
progress to be made and
there we go it is a draw
it is a draw a third row between timora
java and vladislav
wow what is that about oh talking to
himself as well he's okay we know he has
a arbiter sitting in the same room so
he's probably talking to the arbiter
but maybe
suggesting a move here
you could have done this
well definitely this is a new situation
for them it is the first tournament when
arbiters have been placed inside the
rooms of the players do you think it's
very different for them david for sure
previously we've seen players just sit
there in t-shirts and shorts like
they might have just woken up but you
can't do that if there's an armature in
the room you feel like you need to make
more effort and it might make you focus
more but it also could be a slight
distraction depending on the player so
uh i wonder what it's like though
because this arbiter actually has to
come to their home i wonder if they're
like